uh Scooby-Doo a delightful gang of teens
with the help of their trusty Great Dane
cruising around in their old mystery
machine getting into all sorts of
scrambles what's not to love about this
fun group dating all the way back to
1969 I mean they've done it all real
threats Supernatural threats hooped it
up with the Harlem Globetrotters hell
even a couple of mildly horny live
action movies so with such a proven IP
that has stood the test of time any
Rider anywhere could seemingly craft
something you oh dear lord uh um uh yeah
I take that back because Velma is a
thing a thing that uh honestly honestly
an insufferable nasty dumpster fire is
being nice here but uh I'm your host
Jared a huge thank you for clicking this
because we're gonna be talking about uh
yeah why Velma is a big old steamy turd
so yeah Velma Scooby-Doo spin-off origin
story that is supposed to follow the
origins of the gang before they got into
the old mystery business game a
respectable way to take the series even
solely showcasing the uh probably most
overlooked member of the group Velma and
focusing on her point of view and the
jinkies that she finds herself in but uh
about maybe 7.3 percent and that's being
generous of what I just mentioned
actually shows up in the show Velma
Daphne Fred Shaggy uh actually you're
you're not Shaggy and basically they're
outfits from the original series are the
only things that make it into this adult
animated adaptation everything else is
entirely Stripped Away and maybe the
furthest thing from what a Scooby-Doo
fan would want which is hilarious
because this series should be appealing
to Scooby-Doo lovers like zoink scoob
let's watch but instead alienates them
because this this ain't scoob and if
Velma can't get the Scooby-Doo fans on
its side well then adults who love
animated shows are gonna love this right
man if I ever even think about getting
into 420 420 culture or especially 420
related humor kill me you know what 420
is right
um yeah it's code for adults who still
watch cartoons ah what the [__]
who the heck is Velma for if they're
throwing their whole prospective
audience under the bus because I've seen
Eight Episodes which I begrudgingly
watched and I still haven't a damn clue
okay reeling things back a little bit
Velma the show is called Velma she is
the main character boom we got that but
instead of the inquisitive smart clever
mystery solver take on the character
from The Source material Mindy calling
and the writers chose to take the route
of more of like a 2023 version of Daria
but ramped up the know-it-all mean
snarky in a bad way I'm better than you
bitchiness of the character that
honestly resembles nothing like the
character and in the case of a mean
unlikable character Trope usually you
hate them at first they go through a
whole transformation they see things
from a different eye and then at the end
you adore them and you relate after
seeing their their Journey perfect yeah
none of that [__] is here Velma is just
as mean-spirited self-absorbed character
who I cannot I just cannot like and even
Eight Episodes in she's just as mean
also what the heck is this
who are you if I tell you will you she
can just see with her glasses now oh my
God what the apps
okay now this liberal and I mean very
loose interpretation of the character
spreads out to everyone and everything
else with Daphne being the Regina George
Mean Girl of the high school having two
moms swinging both ways while Fred
embodies a mama's boy the white male
Alpha misogynistic couldn't possibly do
anything wrong superiority complex
because he's had life so easily since
birth and only sees women as objects now
Shaggy or I guess Norville is the only
character that is like borderline the
same aim as a source material now I
don't care if there are gender race
cultural sexual differences or swaps
being applied to these characters go for
it because I'm pretty sure that the
whole gang was finger popping in the
mystery machine so when that Vans are
rocking don't come a knocking but the
entirety of Velma feels like it's a
ghost of what Scooby-Doo actually is
like this is a crass teen drama
relationship based finding yourself High
School show with a pinch just a little
pinch of mystery solving it's almost
like the creators had a script for this
type of show already mapped out but
desperately needed to attach it to a
well-known IP well-established one
otherwise the execs would not green
lighted and sure enough the Scooby-Doo
name was thrown out and boom bam done
green like that honestly I'm convinced
that in algorithms spit out this series
and this is how the whole pitch went
down get on your phones scour the
internet and
Scooby-Doo this because they definitely
scoured the internet for some of the
worst references to simply just
reference in the show oh yeah a huge
basis of the comedy and jokes in Velma
is simply referencing something and then
applying this reference to the situation
the characters are in this is obviously
99 of what makes Family Guy Family Guy
but here in Velma it is so poorly done
but more specifically done in a way to
tear down others or stereotypical tropes
in the show but then continue to follow
the same worn out Trend but since they
made the note of it being a cliched it
makes them doing it cheeky sarcastic
smart and fun oh this is Kennedy I'm
having fun a prime example of this is
how the opening talks about how pilot
episodes of shows usually front load
with racy nudity to draw in viewers get
more views and how that's so hacky they
wouldn't do anything like that but then
continues to do that
oh God he looks like Hitler and not just
because we compare everyone to Hitler
these days come on it's also hilariously
ignorant in the fact that the writers
for Velma want to tackle and break down
prejudices stereotype sexism Etc and
lean into a progressive attitude no
they're ignorant
oh well horribly done because at the end
they end up doing exactly what they are
trying to make an argument against by
then ripping down say the stereotypical
white male how they shouldn't have
feelings and how this or that about a
woman oh okay sir I don't need your
mansplaining who you are to me there's
something funny about you not LOL funny
but more thoughtful and well observed
like a female driven comedy it's so
counterproductive and it almost comes
off literally like hey not to be an
[__] but and Then followed by
something asshole-esque is is that even
a word it's nothing but ironic hypocrisy
in the most unironic way it's like the
writers Mindy calling whoever were
bullied back in middle school high
school picked last in DodgeBall and had
all of this pent up anger that came off
in the writing it really feels like a
personal attack to certain groups like
the popular or rich kids that everyone
went to high school with so this
constant barrage of pseudo venting is
apparently looked at as comedy I I guess
some of the jokes are really not even
jokes like Fred has a small penis it's
just that that it stated no punchline or
anything it's just a tiny BB they set up
everything for a smart commentary take
walking a tightrope but take the low
brow path for an outdated 2007's late
night monologue joke rather than saying
anything noteworthy and yes the question
on everyone's mind
[Music]
the iconic mascot of Mystery
Incorporated
is nowhere to be seen the writers all
yelled that fun-loving great dane for uh
no no reason scoob is just he's
non-existent but someone thought that
they were a damn genius because even
though the old pup is not present they
do make a reference to him in one of the
most bizarre and Bland ways possible via
a secret project velma's mom was
researching called Scooby with an eye
standing for special covert operations
brain initiative and you not this is how
they give a wink wink nod to the doggo
Scooby Scooby and wait what did Scooby
Do What I mean come on cheap and cringy
it's almost as bad as movies or shows
turning to the audience turning to the
screen and saying the title of the show
or movie well it was some kind of
Suicide Squad
now I will say that there are a couple
delicious treats in this otherwise
steaming pile of Scooby doggy do and
that's the animation and visual gags
some of the action sequences
specifically velma's hallucinations add
this vibrant bright chaoticness to the
otherwise dull High School drama and the
visual gags being the best pun jokes of
the entire series scattered throughout
in the background starting with the
different clubs at the school with the
different debate clubs which I thought
was decent but one of the best examples
of this is later on in the series they
go to mount Crystal Woods to kind of
investigate or whatever and the mountain
is in the shape of Billy Crystal's face
mount Crystal Billy Crystal
Peak visual pun gag so for those I'll
give it a nice Scooby snack or two but
aside from that there's numerous reasons
this currently is the worst rated TV
show ever the lowest of the low the
garbage inside the garbage the
Cockroaches wow yes uh cockroaches from
the garbage and this this actually
happens in the show anyway I'd be very
curious what your thoughts of Velma are
was this the Flaming pile of doggy doo
that everyone has unanimously kind of
agreed on or is there something special
hidden in there that uh kind of made you
fall in love with Velma and I'll let you
know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
wakanda Forever on the 15th of February
and all you gotta do to get a chance of
winning this baby is like this video
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment Down Below on uh just Velma
anything about the series we picked the
comments at random at the end of every
single month in the winners of last
month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want some
something else to watch be sure to check
out all of our other videos right over
there tons of stuff The Last of Us fever
baby but with that out of the way thank
you for your constant support I've been
Jared this has been Velma and I'll see
you in the next one take care and peace